it's the way we are it's the way I've
always remembered it being people have
always been hospitable and caring and
welcoming ever since I was a kid ever
since I remember the foundation started
when my late grandmother got sick she
was diagnosed with cancer and she passed
away and so I care about fighting this
disease giving people a chance so now
with the Clara Lionel foundation
everything seems the emotion of course I
can't do it alone and that's why I'm
partnering up with so many people they
care as much as I care we're working on
the oncology department in Barbados at
the Queen Elizabeth Hospital and we're
looking to expand and do more things if
we can help facilitate a better future
these people that's what I care about I
wanted to use to become aware I want
them to be safe I want them to enjoy
life and have a life and have a chance
at it if I can save one life if I can
give someone an extra day an extra week
and actually year an extra ten years
it's completely worth it this is exactly
what this is about
like